Good morning, John.
The star that you saw in your last video was
in fact not a star, it was Jupiter.
You can tell that it's a planet one, because
it is so bright and two, because planets do
not twinkle the way that stars do.
This is because planets are much closer to
us, so instead of seeing just a point of light
like we do with stars, we actually see lots
of points of light in a tiny, tiny little
disk.
The moving different layers of different densities
of our atmosphere cause the light from the
single point source to jiggle, and the light
from the little disks jiggle as well, but
all the different points tend to average each
other out, so planets appear much more constant
in their brightness.
So twinkle, twinkle little star- stars don't
actually twinkle.
They are also very constant in their brightness;
our atmosphere just makes it look like they're
twinkling.
Another lie we tell to children!
Like the tortoise and the hare.
That's just- no.
I don't care how much the hare messes around,
the hare's gonna win.
A hare's top speed is like 45 miles per hour.
Slow and steady doesn't win the race, John.
You know who wins the race?
Fast and steady, almost exclusively.
Though, it occurs to me, having said this,
that hares actually have very short lifespans
and tortoises live for, like, ever.
So maybe if the "race" is the amount of distance
an animal can cover in its lifetime, maybe
then, maybe a tortoise could win?
I'm gonna do some math.
Okay, we're back!
No, um, the oldest tortoise in the world is
named Jonathan, and he is 182 years old.
His top speed is 0.17 miles per hour, meaning
that if he travelled every hour of his life,
and there have been more than 1.5 million
of them, he would have by now travelled about
271 thousand miles.
At 45 miles per hour, a hare would only need
13% of its five year life span to eclipse
the tortoise.
So yeah, hare versus Jonathan, in a really
terribly hypothetical in which neither of
them ever sleep or rest, the hare still wins.
Though the hare has been dead for a hundred
and seventy seven years...
So.
Maybe the real moral of the story is Slow
and Steady Loses the Race But Who Cares As
Long As You're Not Dead.
Thanks to Jonathan the oldest tortoise, and
also the oldest John, for teaching us that
one.
Come on, John, you tell the history of Johns
and you forget the oldest John ever?
You're slacking, that's all I'm saying.
Here's another interesting bit of John trivia:
there might be more forms of John than there
are forms of any other name.
Jane, Gianni, Juan, Ivan, Janice, Joan, Ian,
Yanni-
Yeah, Yanni.
These are just a few.
Lots of them start with that J noise, 'J-uh'.
But if you say a J noise without messing with
the air as it's coming out of your mouth,
it's just a Y noise.
You have John, and you have Yahn.
And Y noises are weird, because they are never
consonants.
Yet another lie that we tell to children!
Y noises are two vowel sounds shoved together
really quick.
Like with 'your', you don't get to a consonant
until you get to the r.
It's just 'Ee-yore'.
Eeyore.
Eeyore, Eeyore, your, your, your, your.
W's are like this too.
When you say Wednesday, you- there's no consonant.
You say 'Oo-ens-day'.
It's just vowels!
When two vowel sounds are slapped together,
you get one of the coolest words in the English
language, the 'dipthong'.'Dipthongs' are everywhere,
we're pretty bad at hearing them, but even
in simple words, like Mike- 'mi-eek'. 'a-ee'.
You see it written down sometimes, like 'oil',
o-i-l.
When we put a 'dipthong' in place of a consonant,
as breaking two syllables apart, it basically
is acting like a consonant, but it's not a
consonant.
So we call it semi-vowel.
In fact, the name that 'John' came from, 'Iohannes,'
it's actually all spelled out there for everybody
to see, all the vowels.
It also shows the origin of the silent H,
because John basically used to be Johan.
Now for a piece of seemingly random information:
Middle English used the suffix '-kin' to put
on the end of words that meant it was a small
thing.
Like if there was a kid named Tom, you would
call him Tomkin.
Or a small piece of cloth, would be called
a clothkin, except their word for cloth was
nap, so it would be a napkin.
The Middle English shortened Johan to Han,
and when there was a little person named Han,
they would call him Hankin.
Which, I am not even kidding, is how the name
Hank first appeared.
John, you and I have the same name!
I'll see you on Monday.